let us see now what consciousness
experiences in its actual perceiving for
us this experience is already contained
in the development of the object and if
the attitude of consciousness towards it
just given just now it is only a matter
of developing the contradictions that
are present there in the object which I
apprehend presents itself purely as a
one but I also perceive in it a property
which is universal and which thereby
transcends the singularity of the object
the first being of the objective
essences of one was therefore not it's
true being
but since the object is what is true the
untruth falls in me my apprehension was
not correct an account of the
universality of the property I must
rather take the objective essence to be
on the whole a community I now further
perceive the property to be determinate
opposed to another and excluding it thus
I did not in fact apprehend the
objective essence correctly when I
defined it as a community with others or
as a continuity on account of the
determinate Ness of the property I must
break up the continuity and posit the
objective essence as a one that excludes
in the broken up one I find many such
properties which do not affect one
another but which but are mutually
indifferent therefore I did not perceive
the object correctly when I apprehended
it as exclusive on the contrary just as
previously it was only continuity in
general so now it is a universal common
medium in which many properties are
present in sensuous universalities each
existing on its own account and as
determinate excluding the others but
this being so what I perceive as as
simple and the true isn't also not a
universal medium but the single property
buying itself which however is such is
neither a property nor a determinate
being for now it is neither in a one nor
connected with others only when it
belongs to a one is it a property and
only in relation
others is it determinate as is pure
relating of itself to itself it remains
merely sensuous being in general since
it no longer possesses the character of
negativity and the consciousness which
takes its object to be a sensuous being
is only mine meaning it is ceased
altogether to perceive and has withdrawn
into itself but sensuous being in mind
meaning themselves pass over into
perception I am thrown back to the
beginning and drawn once again into the
same cycle which supersedes itself in
each moment and as a whole
while we see Hegel doing in Section 117
this very long section is actually a
sort of summary and recap of what has
been happening in the sections just
preceding it in perception so he's going
to start out uh saying let's see now
what consciousness experiences in its
actual perceiving for us this experience
is already contained in the development
of the object and the attitude of
consciousness given just now what we've
run through up to this point so then he
goes on and he is giving us an idea of
where this is supposed to go remember
that we always have dialectical
development taking place which is we
have a process that we run through and
then we see that something else must be
going on and we want to try to make that
explicit we want to try to bring that to
light so that we can make some progress
from that point progress that's going to
retain what we've what we've got to live
up developed up until this point so that
we're not just throwing everything away
but rather incorporating and what Hegel
calls sublation or in German a label so
he says it's a matter of developing the
contradictions that are present therein
and we've seen him doing that but now
we're going to run through these
contradictions one more time
he says the object which I prefer had
presents itself purely as a one as some
sort of unity so for example this book
is an object it is a one the biggest
piece of track that I've been using as
an example of Ren Oregon is a unity of
one so we have consciousness and
consciousness is looking at or
perceiving in some way experiencing an
object and the object is experienced as
a one so far so good he says I also
perceiving it a property which is
universal which thereby transcends the
singularity of the object and this can
take place in multiple ways right we can
think about the one itself and how we're
framing that in terms of multiple
properties we can also think of that
property that universal it's a universal
because it can apply to more than one
thing and it's the same property more or
less in the suit the two pieces of white
chalk right
same whiteness it's the same hardness
there's a sensuous universality that we
find transcending the object the one and
a line with other objects so we can
think of the universal as also what is
connecting the two ones or multiple ones
together so he goes on he says the first
being of the objective essence is one
was therefore not its true being we've
had some sort of realization we've
recognized that truth was not where we
thought it was but since the object is
what is true up until this point the
untruth falls in me like I could
overhear consciousness in this this part
of perception is saying well if anything
got wrong if there was any untruth that
comes to light anything that doesn't
actually match or or follow through or
is inadequate it's on the side of
consciousness it's on the side of the
perceiver this is what we just finished
with in the end of section 116 talking
about the possibility of a deception of
illusion bonzi right so he goes on and
he says on account of the universality
of the property I have to take the
objective essence to be on the whole a
community now what does he mean by that
he means that now we're distributing
truth or assets or what is the case what
is what what is real we're distributing
it not in just one thing in one one but
rather into a community and we're doing
this in multiple ways that he's not
making totally explicit here the one
itself is already a community that's
where we're going to be going with this
but the one is also in a community in
the way that we perceive the world with
other ones I can perceive this as a
piece of chalk because it's not the only
piece of chalk in the world it's not
what we call in classical studies a hot
box like omana that means a Greek word
that shows up only once it's said only
once a single time a hot box legoman on
when it shows up in a Greek text we
don't actually know what it means
because
unless somebody's actually defined it we
can't figure out through its relations
to other things how to pin down that
meaning and why can't we pin down that
meaning very simply because it's not
available in multiple things where we
can look at it and do some comparison
when it comes to universalities it's the
fact that they're present in more than
one thing in a community that allows us
to perceive them as universals so he
says I did not I pretend the objective
essence correctly when I defined it as a
community with others or as a continuity
on account of the determinate Nisour the
property I must break up the continuity
and posit the objective essence as a one
that excludes so we've seen those two
right the one is the one by not being
the other one the property is the
property by not being the other property
I've got that sort of depicted here as
we move to the more sophisticated view
that he is his put out in the last
several paragraphs each property is
itself a universality each involves a
negation the other properties by way of
being what it is that's what allows it
to have determinacy so you know in the
salt the saltiness is not the same thing
as the whiteness is not the same thing
as the cubical nature is not the same
thing as the the you know sharpness or
however we want to define it so he says
I must break up the continuity posit the
objective essence as a one that excludes
in the broken up one so there's one over
here I find many such properties which
do not affect one another but which are
mutually different so we've taken away
negation at that point we have just
properties we're talking about it as we
had earlier where it's a indifferent
medium you remember the instead of the
one the also so the also allows these
properties to be in relation to each
other but not to really matter to each
other now to connect with each other not
push off that's another way you might
think of a galleon negation pushing off
of each other instead they're they're
connected with each other just by being
in the same thing as soon as we try to
make that determinant as soon as we want
to go further with this we end up
starting to introduce some reliefs some
contrast into this where something is
not another thing there's opposition
there's negation so he says I didn't
perceive the object correctly when I am
prohibited as an exclusive on the
contrary was previously just continuity
in general it's a common medium and
that's not going to work though right
many properties are present as sensuous
universalities each existing at its own
account how can they exist on their own
account well only by being in relation
to each other in a way that's more than
just also more than just the medium here
so he goes on and he says as determinate
they exclude the others so if this is so
what I perceive is the simple and the
true for example this property here this
is where the true is it's not a
universal medium it's not the one itself
it's rather the single property by
itself now notice what he's going to do
here he's going to introduce a number of
interesting you might say almost even
paradoxical considerations if we're
thinking about a single property by
itself in an abstraction from everything
else we're not really thinking the
single property as a property why not
because what it means to be a property
is two things it has to be a property of
something so it's a property of the one
not just a property existing in a you
know valueless
doesn't affect it at all sort of medium
like something floating in a petri dish
that's not the way properties of things
ontological II work so it can't be a
property unless it's part of something
unless it's a property that exists in
community but then what does it exist in
community with is the second thing in
relation to other properties and on each
of these we can say these are true two
can't wait but then we have truth in a
you might say oppositional or negation
elationship with something else that's
true it's a matter of our shifting our
perspective so when we're attending to
the whiteness of the truck we are you
know pushing off or not attending to or
you know setting aside the other
qualities of the truck if the more that
we're focusing on the whiteness the less
we're focusing on the dryness or the
hardness of it so he goes on and he says
the true is is the single property by
itself which as such is neither property
nor a determinate being why because it's
neither on one nor connected with others
only when it belongs to a one is that a
property only in relation to others is
it determinate and unless you want it to
be an indeterminate property you got to
have both of these together there really
isn't an indeterminate property anyway
he's saying these are two conditions
that have to be met it has to be part of
a one it has to exist in relation to
other properties so notice what this
would also exclude he doesn't go over
this here but but that would exclude
anything where you had a one a unity a
thing that only had one property for a
thing to be a thing means that it has
multiple properties there are multiple
points of view by which you can look at
it multiple ways in which you can grasp
its truth so you're going to he says as
is pure relating of itself to itself it
remains merely sensuous being in general
since it no longer possesses the
character of negative
that's what we're trying to get away
from right and the consciousness which
takes its object to be a sensuous being
is only my meaning my intent what's
taking place through perception what I'm
just focusing on one property in
isolation from everything else there's a
kind of idiocy a kind of idiosyncrasy
involved they're kind of abstractness
that doesn't even realize that it's lost
hold of the truth and where
consciousness goes wrong is though the
untruth is just on my side it's not
actually on the side of the object
nothing's going on there that's untrue
so he says sensuous being in my meeting
themselves pass over into perception I'm
thrown back to the beginning and drawn
once again into the same cycle which
supersedes itself in each moment and as
a whole so what is he concluding with
their each time that we follow through
this each time that we go through this
sequence what we're running into is the
same dynamic playing itself out and now
we've been able to see how the
contradictions emerge from this act of
perception the question is where are we
going to go from here
consciousness therefore necessarily runs
through this cycle again but this time
not in the same ways it did the first
time for it is experienced in perception
that the outcome and the truth of
perception is its dissolution or is
reflection out of the true and into
itself thus it becomes quite definite
for consciousness how its perceiving is
essentially constituted that is that it
is not a simple pure apprehension but in
its apprehension is at the same time
reflected out of the true and into
itself this return of consciousness into
itself which is directly mingled with
the pure a prevention of the object for
this return into its self has shown
itself to be essential to perception
alter is the truth consciousness at once
recognizes this aspect as its own and
takes responsibility for it for but by
doing so it will obtain the true object
in its purity this being so we have now
in the case of perception the same has
happened in this in the case of sense
certainty the aspect of consciousness
being driven back into itself
but not in the first instance in the
sense in which this happened in sense
certainty that is not as if the truth of
perception fell unconsciousness
on the contrary consciousness recognizes
that it is the untruth occurring in
perception that falls within it but by
this very recognition it is able at once
to supersede this untruth it
distinguishes its apprehension of the
truth from the untruth of its perception
corrects this untruth and since it
undertakes to make this correction
itself the truth qua truth of perception
falls of course within consciousness the
behavior of consciousness which we have
now to consider is thus so constituted
that consciousness no longer merely
perceives but is also conscious of its
reflection into itself and separates
this from simple apprehension proper
if section 117 was simply restating and
retracing what had gone on so far in the
previous sections of perception what
we're going to see happen now in section
118 is an important transition point a
realization on the part of consciousness
and remember what's going on with the
phenomenology is we're tracing out the
development of consciousness by
observing it as it actually works and we
ourselves are that consciousness at the
same time as we're observing it or we're
attempting to at least pretend that's
that's what's going on well it's a sort
of fiction that we're using in order to
try to get a sense of how we actually do
in fact perceive things what is the
truth of perception now you remember
that so far any untruth in perception
has been located on the side of
consciousness and the truth of
perception was located in the object the
object was sort of given a pass there
couldn't be any untruth on its side
because that's what we're attempting to
make sense of and consciousness was in a
certain sense very very generous to the
object by saying well if I've got
anything wrong it must be because I got
it wrong it took responsibility of the
term that Cagle is going to use here it
took responsibility for the falsity the
the mistake for the illusion for the
self-deception that's occurring is that
really the whole story though this is
where we're going to see an important
transition take place so we've got
consciousness we've got the active
perception we have the object and we've
seen all these transitions that we don't
need to you know rehearse anymore the
transition from the universal medium in
which things are in in juxtaposition
with each other through the also to the
one which is a unity which excludes
others we've seen the property involves
negation which then allows it to have
universality which is its precondition
for being a property in the first place
there's multiple properties all that we
don't need to actually go back over
again but what we do want to point out
is that's the truth of perception so if
somebody were to ask at this point wait
a second Hegel I don't understand what
is the
truth of perception Hegel would say well
it's this dynamic system that I've
charted out for you
it's not just one thing like a equals B
that's rather that here's what a is and
here's what a shows itself as it unfolds
that it involves BCD and each one of
them also involved the truth here is
something complex so the truth of
perception has now been grasped by
consciousness because consciousness has
been paying attention to its own
processes and it sees that when it first
thought it was perceiving something it
doesn't wait what we might call the the
raw the crew the naive act of perception
things didn't actually turn out to be
quite the way they were depicted and so
now as Hegel is going to put it
it's experienced in perception that the
outcome and the truth of perception is
its disillusion or as reflection out of
the truth of perception and into itself
what's he talking about there what Hegel
is saying is that consciousness has not
just learned something about the object
in all of this it's learned something
about itself it has confronted itself
with the truth of perception and looked
at how it got it wrong in the first
place so he calls this you know
dissolution you know breaking down in a
feeling right but that's taking place
through this reflection into itself and
now that's always going to be an
important thing whenever some sort of
reflection into itself is taking place
that's the side where progress is going
to be made and then Hegel will talk
about a mingling a bringing together of
these two things the reflection into
itself and the original perception what
does that do
that calls into question the truth of
perception he says it becomes quite
definite for consciousness consciousness
how its perceiving is essentially
constituted it's not a simple pure
apprehension but it is an apprehension
at the same time reflected out of the
true and into itself this return of
consciousness into itself which mingles
the pure apprehension the object of
initial perception and the return to
itself alters the truth so what we took
to be a fixed point we at least we said
well at least this part we've got down
we know that there's a truth over here
turns out is it's been altered so he
says consciousness recognizes this
aspect as its own and again shows this
incredible ontological generosity it
takes responsibility what is
responsibility mean in this case who's
screwed up did the object screw up when
I was perceiving the piece of chalk did
the piece of chalk you know trick me
into thinking that things were not as it
were know my own processes of thinking
about it making sense of it those were
what led me astray so I have to take
responsibility for that as the perceiver
as the one who is actually conscious but
that's gonna have some very important
implications for for spirit he says
consciousness recognizes this aspect as
its own takes responsibility for it by
doing so it will obtain the true object
in its purity now what's the true object
we think that's what it is over here
Dali the true object of perception so if
consciousness can just pay attention to
how it screws things up to where its
filters are where its biases are where
it is over-hasty
may be of consciousness read some
Descartes and realizes that we shouldn't
allow our understanding to outstrip
our desire or our will or something
along those lines then consciousness by
taking responsibility can get a
accurately more true a more genuine
perception of the object that's one way
to interpret it but is that the only way
he says we have now in the case of
perception the same thing that happened
in the case of scent certainty so we
want to remember well what did he happen
in the case of scent certainty as it
turned out the truth of scent certainty
that we thought was on the side of the
object really wasn't on the side of the
object that's why we're in this section
perception in the first place if you
remember at the end of sense certainty
what we realized was that we there was
more than just sense certainty going on
there was perception going on VAR naman
taking the truth of something something
active the truth that's on the side of
the object has to be taken by
consciousness so what else can we say
about this he goes on and any he adds
that the aspect of consciousness being
driven back into itself is what happened
in the case of sensor me there's an
important difference here though not as
if the truth of perception fell in
consciousness that's what that's what
didn't happen in sense certainty and is
happening here on the contrary
consciousness recognizes that it is the
untruth occurring in perception that
falls within it so what am i taking
responsibility for untruth the untruth
within consciousness what does it mean
to take responsibility for untruth it
means to introduce a certain sort of
truthfulness though doesn't it to cop to
having screwed up is to admit something
to say I was telling you something false
is to say something true unless you were
actually making up the fact that you're
saying something falls in the first
place then we get into all sorts of
liars paradoxes and I don't want to
overly complicate that but notice that
by taking responsibility by taking
cognizance of itself as having
introduced the untruth of new truth to
be untrue there into the act of
perception
consciousness is thereby reintroduced
truthfulness into perception he says by
this very recognition it's able at once
to supersede to overcome to take into
account to to incorporate this untruth
that doesn't mean that the untruth
totally goes away but we're able to in
some way redeem it we're enable in some
way to make it part of the whole process
becoming aware of your biases does not
automatically remove your biases but it
certainly equips you for being able to
deal with your biases when they're
likely to occur when they're likely to
be engaged doesn't it that's exactly
what he's talking about here except he's
not talking here about biases and a sort
of moral fashion or anything like that
he's talking about perceptual biases so
he goes on and he says it distinguishes
its apprehension of the truth from the
untruth of its perception corrects this
untruth and since it undertakes to make
this correction itself since it's active
since there is an agency here the truth
qua truth of perception Falls of course
within consciousness so now the truth of
perception is no longer here the truth
of perception has now been sucked into
the realm of consciousness we have
realized that the object no longer
possesses the premise see that it was
being originally granted consciousness
is what makes the object what it is
consciousness is what decides am i
getting the object right in perceiving
it or am i introducing on truth
consciousness is what can adjust for
that on truth and can remedy that
untruth thereby reintroducing truth and
that becomes the greater truth of
perception you remember that earlier I
was saying look this truth of perception
over here it's not something single it's
all these things together another way of
saying it
is now the truth of perception
encompasses all of this together and it
falls within consciousness so that means
that consciousness now has a it's not a
passive in relation to it it's active
it's responsible so he says this the
behavior of consciousness which we now
have to consider is the so constituted
that consciousness no longer merely
perceives perception is no longer
something passive but it is also
conscious of its reflection into itself
it takes account of what's going on in
its own processes and separates us from
simple apprehension proper what might be
some examples of this so we can you know
latch this on to something a bit more
concrete think about the way camouflage
works camouflage is supposed to affect
perception and in many cases it works
quite well as a matter of fact if
camouflage works perfectly you don't
know that camouflage has taken place and
there's a lot of different ways of doing
it they're their natural camouflages
that animals have the white bellies that
that a lot of animals you know that are
land-dwelling have combined to the dark
you know back and sides flanks that sort
of thing that helps to break up the the
profile of the creature so you can't
identify the outlines you can't identify
it in in Hegelian terms as an object as
a one as a unity instead what you see is
just the blank and multifarious
background that the animal is within we
can say the same thing with ships you
know and the dazzle effect we can say
the same thing with hiding things in
plain sight you know with objects we can
say the same thing with body paint is a
form of camouflage and you know if we
think about the kind of camouflage we
have today with you know hunting gear or
or military gear all of those are
supposed to have roughly the same effect
now if you know that that's going on if
you have some experience with that you
can start to adjust in your percept
so that you're not going to be as
affected by it that may be a matter of
experience right so but Kermit can also
be a matter of training or a matter of
knowing how to change your own
conditions of perceptions so that you
have a better chance at perceiving
what's really there in doing so you're
no longer a passive agent of reception I
know that's a little paradoxical to say
passive agent but follow them through
you're an active you're a reflective
agent of perception one that takes
account of his own perception and works
to improve it to make it better to make
it more true to grasp the truth of
perception or better yet said to enact
the truth of perception to make truth
exist